hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my friendly neighborhood
um this is some kind of sesame street
style horror game it's not supposed to
be a mouse in the background because
i'm not gonna lie just looking at it
right now it looks a lot like a douche
like not like an [ __ ] like
like the physical
elixir and put up a side by side so
people don't think i'm crazy okay new
game
this is just the demo the difficulty for
those experienced with survival horror
this will be tough
this could go one of two ways
i'm good at games welcome to the
neighborhood i'm very good at games and
anybody that says otherwise is very
why do i have a shootie
why do i have a shootie why do i have a
shootie with the rolodex on it
r
s
t u v
oh
it's a clever ammo counter actually it
was just a rolodex i'm out of ammo i
probably should have done should not
have done that
that's just my impulsive brain being
like you should do the stupid things
like set it to survival when you've
never played it
i'm sorry so like with most of these um
actually not like with most of these
childhood memory based horror games this
one is a derivative of or you know like
uh inspired by but also seems to have a
bit more oh dear oh my
what the [ __ ] how do i get out of here
ricky oh having a clue never come down
here myself why what's got your overalls
in a knot i'm trying to get to the roof
the roof
look you gotta give up this nonsense
about the antenna looks very bad very
unprofessional it's my job look gordy i
know our routine's a little rough but
don't judge a show by its pilot
incidentally
i would hide again what is it this time
well ray of course he's the best sort of
monster janitor thing but doesn't like
it when people intrude on his territory
tends to get a bit grouchy one might say
assault happy assault happy all of you
puppets crazy well ray has always been a
little grouchy even before the shutdown
that's why they moved him down here only
way out is by elevator and he can't
figure out how to use the buttons
didn't help though he goes through the
pipes elevated got it oh silly me i
forgot about the elevators really gordon
i wouldn't bother the cables are
probably rusted i don't think they even
run anymore i'll take my chances wow
you're so
courageous and stuff look i gotta go
wash my hair
okay i have so many questions you said
that ray uses the pipes but you just
emerged from a pipe so i'm assuming that
he could
jump out and eat my face at any moment
i'm ready ray all right fine um
[Music]
hi i don't think i should have gone in
here
there was a big sign that said ray at
the top and i think i just got a lot of
expositions
okay
[Music]
uh i don't know what to do about this um
[Music]
i don't know i don't know i don't know
i'm in danger
i didn't do too good there and i don't
want to listen to you again so shut up
shut up shut up shut up
i don't need to know you i don't need to
know what you're doing and anything
about you
oh god oh my god
[Music]
oh
uh-huh
am i supposed to um
i didn't get the extra ammo did i
well this is horrifying
exactly the place that i would like to
be all the time the cardboard penthouse
oh my god
i'm used to exploring every room but
apparently
am i not supposed to do that oh
no
hello
this is how i got into the back rooms
before so i'm assuming that it's gonna
happen again
hey you didn't give me any more ammo
i thought you did but you did not can i
have this
let's get right here let's get writing
what do you mean let's get writing be
friendly to your neighbors keep quiet
guests are not permitted children
just children our best cap only
designated areas and far away from the
puppets and lesser handlers present
avoid equipment you are unfamiliar with
no swearing i'm sorry cables wires and
cords dangerous materials be mindful of
custodial staff generally keep the
studio in the same position okay
yes please
this is fascinating it's got a very grim
fandango vibe to it
which i've never actually played grim
fandango but i've seen it be played
okay if what don't walk
okay
fun
don't know what i'm supposed to do
i always eat the food
oh my god
no no no
no no okay
hey stop that please
oh oh my god
okay you keep counting there was a mouse
down there but whatever
uh this is bizarre
it's very bizarre educating the world
about what
about how nightmares can chase you out
of your dreams and exist in real life
is that what you're teaching the world
hi
that's not concerning
oh
benny could you walk me home after the
shoot today i'm feeling a little
unsettled after that mugging on great
street couple nights ago seems like the
city is getting more and more violent
every day some days i feel like the only
safe place is the neighborhood i know
it's silly but it'd mean a lot to me mr
gershwald usually lets me go around 6
30. meet in the office lobby
well i'm guessing julie may not have
made it to the lobby
where is
and fix it's broke they in
read going bad m isn't nothing janitor
who
are
oh it's it's actually just
it's just corrections i thought it was a
secret message
all right fine then that's not scary at
all
check it's locked good
great
duct tape why who knows
hello
how are you
okay
oh my god
[Music]
air is fine
[Music]
oh metal piece good
all right
goodbye i don't have a map i keep
hitting r that's why it says i don't
have a map i don't know why r
are you back up
oh my god you're back
did i get anything important besides
some ammo
and maybe a metal piece
can i stack these no
shells this is so weird it's got like a
resident evil inventory which i love i
always like that i think it's very fun
it's a great way to play on the uh hole
you can't carry everything in the world
all the ones kind of thing i'm just
gonna go for it
don't do that also shut up and go away
i don't think i got any key
i didn't get anything i don't even know
why i went over there i should have
listened to this this stupid sock puppet
over here
you ain't going okay but the good news
is i've learned that i can actually
shoot those things and eventually they
will go down
which should be the point
time to
write words or whatever
[Music]
when enemies are knocked over you can
tape them look at an enemy and press e
you can
bring yesterday's leftovers
x
what do you mean x
stop oh my god if i keep getting hit by
that i'm just gonna go down
stop stop stop stop what's with the r
i mean i know that i'm shooting letters
here but uh
i have a few questions
i feel like the full game is going to
explain some things maybe later
weird choco zip yes please use yum what
did that do
i don't know health-o-lax
health and a laxative great
i'm sorry
yo you're okay okay it's all good i
apologize
everything's fine i'm not gonna go to
the stage first because that seems too
obvious they'd expect me at the stage
i'm gonna sneak up on them or they least
expect me
not the stage or maybe i'm supposed to
be metal piece
i know what he's i i i yes i
i totally get it and i understand
i need to use this move no yes no yes
yeah
it's clear that that goes there
uh
looks like it needs power
the plug seems oh it's pr i probably
only have a piece of the plug
three
was this a voting booth what am i
looking at here
weird uh oh don't fall
i'll try not to
no promises though
oh my god
so that's locked is that a health oh
lacks perfect
ricky with friends
great
[Music]
zip zap here comes the signal
great
tools
oh
a
smooth
really uh good stuff sewers soundstage
basement completed in progress oh
do i get the color
i have a map now
ah
it is very resident evil
which i like it's just not that i'm used
to it in a um sesame street style
environment but whatever
i'll take it sure what does this do
public safe station public health
station i have tokens
say please
i don't know how that works
but that's super cool it's so stylish
it's got style i don't need health
i'll uh do health if i die again but at
least i'm saved there so
if i do die then it's not too much
progress lost
uh this machine is remotely controlled
and may start without warning
why
so i'm willing to bet that i need to
like construct something out of the pug
and the pug the plug
and
it's probably
what i say on the front of that gordon
gordon
how did i even get this job
how did gordon
[Music]
got me all upset at him
first i uh
i beat him to the ground
then i uh like stopped i stopped his
face
then we started laughing at each other
and everything was okay
that's why you should always try to make
friends with friends who will forgive
you
i i i feel like if i listen to that
insanity for too long it will infect my
brain and it probably has already
affected many of you
infected and affected
what
what is any of that
what is happening
huh hey
who's
huh
who's there
hello
i don't know anything about what's
happening
uh uh oh bonk okay
all right i guess i'll go then hi
who's uh
oh hi
hello
how are you
my name is markiplier i'm here to uh
bonk you i think is what i'm gonna do
episode 27 segment rey's plumbing
nightmare uh oh boy where's rey room
shakes water flushing oh my goodness
what's happening don't flush away your
problems from shakespeare splashes down
ray if we don't get this problem taken
care of the whole sewer system explode
destroying the entire city
huh
why would you do that why would he do
that
the clunk hi oh god what are you
oh
jeez that gave me a scare
what was that what yeah what what was
that
okay
i really feel like i shouldn't turn my
back
on uh
hi
oh now that pipe
i feel like that'd be a terrible idea
i've had many terrible ideas so i know
all about terrible ideas
i'm gonna drink this healtholax
i'm healthy
stop let's fix it
yeah let's um
okay
hey
i've got my back turned
boy do i have just a thing for you
what are you referring to um because
you're being ambiguous about this and
because i don't have much context on the
situation i'm assuming that you mean
your penis and uh if you mean anything
else
i will uh accept that as being
completely wrong yay i was wrong unless
that's your penis
oh
shoot what happened
what happened
what happened what happened i didn't
even see what happened
what is happening
why do i hate it so much
why do i hate you don't even think about
it don't even
nope
oh my god what
why
okay so there's gotta be probably a way
to do this bulk i see x's on the floor
and i saw a sign that said bonk so that
makes me think that i need to bonk you
oh my god oh oh my god i don't know how
that happened
[Music]
okay
i'm gonna not question anything that
just happened about the the the absolute
duplication of of anything
[Music]
hi how are
[Music]
no no no this is the hallway of madness
and i'm not going to be a part of this
i'm going to go save at the save station
and i'm going to feel a lot better about
myself and my chances for the future
why
oh it's the music
okay
okay
ah
that's probably helpful
i'll get that in just a moment
save please thank you uh
okay
three
x x
that circle there what was that did a
car just pass by in the sewer um
yeah it's got to be something about this
relating to this square plus two okay
there's three here that could be
referring to a triangle so minus one but
i don't even know why that would be i'll
look at it again later uh once i get a
better understanding of what i'm doing
this is cool like this is one of the
demos one of those demos that i played
that i actually
really want to see get made oh
ah
what
what what what what
what
ah
ah
i get it now whoa i actually did that
right
okay but i don't know what uh three i
don't know what x means besides ten
maybe and i don't know why that's that
would be nine but it's x'd out not nine
circle is seven so i think that's
supposed to be seven and i think that's
supposed to be ten
so to get ten oh hi
due to the ongoing renovation of the
deeper stages a high security door has
been installed to keep puppets out of
the construction zone every employee's
been issued a set of punch cards for
opening the door if you lose your punch
cards this machine could be used to
generate replacements okay so if i
recall
square was two plus two triangle was
minus one and circle was plus six so if
i wanted to get to 10 it would be uh
well basically just
circle square square
i think
thank you
i hope
okay
and i think this one if it's supposed to
be seven and not nine
i don't know why that's been scribbled
out it just needs circle square triangle
i guess just all the all the ones
okay i love technology
oh
i did it or i didn't do it i don't know
what i did hey
hi
surely this can't be good
oh god where am i
hello
well i'm not gonna go down that way
because there's a
sewer grate there
oh god i can't go this way
well i guess i know what's in store for
me
hi
ray ray
i don't know if
i don't know if it just intelligently
preconditioned me to be afraid of those
openings but i am afraid of those
openings so if that was the intention
then good job you did it you done did do
it and i'm proud of you
good
a boat
uh oh deep in stinky water
okay
why am i driving this
i guess like
what where did i just go
pipe room
huh what
is that where i am are you saying this
is where i am
custom storage what huh
ah
i see
okay public save station
um
maybe maybe not
yeah i was half expecting another puppet
in there
all right oh heel oh i was already
healthy
consider seeking asthma treatment you
should get more exercise i'm trying
i'm trying to do that
great
if what don't walk
good advice
great advice actually isn't this where i
was before
yeah whim
okay let me go back i don't need to go
back here i don't think i haven't gotten
any keys or anything like that so there
should be no reason
what did i just see behind me
there was like a shadow that moved over
was there not was there not a shadow
that moved this is just a railing
what is causing it was like a shadow i
saw it
okay
i'd like to think that i'm just burnt
from the invincible
stomping around here
okay well that was fun and i wasted the
token getting healthier than i ever was
but hey
that's just a theory
a game theory
and if you don't know who bert is go
check out my
uh
latest show in ah
developers i see
never mind
[Music]
i'm sorry
go see my latest show in space with
markiplier very fun put a lot of work
into all my god
this is a gun this is a real gun no it's
not
[Music]
god no don't do that to me i forgot that
they're not like stunned or anything
okay i don't have much tape but i'm
gonna try
i feel like i could have a more
effective weapon
than what is essentially a typewriter
also what are you doing over there and
why are you doing it and why do i
what's with the big hole
who designed any of this
why design any of this
hi don't look at me like that god
ugh
okay goodbye
probably some weird magic in this world
that i don't want to know about oh
[Music]
[ __ ] away slowly i'm gonna back away
slowly i'm gonna back away
i suppose
i'm fine well this is not a room that
anybody should be in um
oh
there's more
are there even more lurking in the i
legitimately like super swallowed my
spit
okay anyway um
i'm just gonna i'm gonna go
i'm a meanie you are trying to kill me
maybe you don't understand the the
repercussions of your actions but i am
i'm definitely aware of it
working in this place must be an
absolute delight and not a nightmare
definitely i only have one token left
because i wasted on the health i didn't
want to can i have some stuff please
no
all right fine whatever
um
thank you oh token thank you
there's probably a lot of like little
secret stuff like that that i have not
found
i just don't know how to find it um is
this wait
oh
i need to find the red
rhombus key
i don't trust
i i don't what makes you not move and
what makes the other one so you move now
why did you explode into 13 different
versions of you
i have a lot of questions that i need
addressing
don't like it
okay
yeah
okay
oh strange kind of breaker box
looks like a face but why
but why
okay everything has an electric latch um
i don't have any fuses or anything like
that so i don't really know what to do
nothing in there
something in here at least they're
giving me plenty of ammo
okay the only other way that i know to
go is where that other dude no boy
i didn't tie this one down
okay i'm gonna go i'm gonna go i'm gonna
go over here now
um
ooh some vegetation that's nice hey is
this yellow oh
okay so i need to figure out a way to
get power here but i don't remember
anything that could have been like i
guess the fuse box but i didn't get any
fuses okay it's a weird nightmare room i
don't have that i have not completed
ray's stage or this area here
or the puppet storage hi
oh
why
why why
why are you automatically in the hug
position
hi
frankly friendly
i wonder what happens when i sleep when
you
sw when you so what they will clamor
until your ears
oh god i really didn't i thought i was
gonna escape
oh no come on oh no no nope nope nope
nope nope nope there we go
i thought i was gonna make it around you
guys but i did not
it turns out that i did not i was not
able to do that
god what do you want
what do you want sir
i just don't i feel like it would be
death
well i was right about that
okay i wonder if all those things are
still here there's probably oh they're
not
okay unless it was like oh hello well no
that's not what i needed it does say
that there's something else here though
oh no wait no there's nothing else here
oh it was just the ammo that i didn't
get kind of insane life to these puppets
live what kind of brains do they operate
on
high
wham
get
wrecked [ __ ]
that's what you get that's what you get
that's what you get
an electric lock
an electric latch
those oh oh
my god
oh come on
oh
i just went through the whole goddamn
thing again
that's what i just did actually lixie
and make it so that i didn't just do
that and i was much better about
what i was supposed to do and how was i
supposed to just to do it
okay cool
thanks for making me look so good high
five how boom i'm gonna assume that you
definitely made me look good right
otherwise that high five would be
completely unwarranted
[Music]
also apparently subtitles are not
working i did turn them on a while ago
but oh this is probably gonna be bad
here we go click click i'm out of here
okay goodbye
good thing i'm such a good shot and good
thing i can twirl my gun
even though it doesn't seem like it does
anything and i don't know why i do it
give
oink joint
okay good and there was one more aha
okay easy peasy good good good
no thank you
[Music]
i wonder what happens when i scream
we can teach them we can teach them
now
let's be excellent let's be excellent
let's be excellent
take some time
ow
i'm going i'm going i'm going i'm going
i'm going i know that they probably did
that so that you know they wouldn't kill
you if you go in the thing but i almost
damn dead and i don't want to die
thank you okay
oh boy all right i need to go back up
there
hi pal
i still don't remember what the uh
journal was how do i get to the journal
settings controls files
aha okay so club diamond heart spade
club diamond heart spade you got it club
diamond heart
club
spade diamond
yay
why did that only do one of them
why
why was it only oh
why don't you eat these letters oh god
i'm sorry
i thought it was gonna be better than
that
hello oh that's not a suitcase i can
open well i can't tape you but i'm
assuming i'm going to be okay
so i'm not going to
worry about that
sure
right
i didn't mean to shoot that that
actually scared me
well just wasted a bullet
promoting smoking how could you
oh god another boat
a big bell
if i shoot that will it ring-a-ding-ding
nope
useless where am i going i don't care
but show me to my destiny
[Music]
it unlocked what unlocked where am i
oh
but i
don't think this
actually helped me
did i not get a key of some kind
why would dad the only place that has
not been explored is here but i didn't
get into the editing room because i
didn't open that door
and this is still blocked off that's not
that's still blocked off so where do i
go
hey
hey what do i do hey what do i do i
don't i haven't fixed the power problem
or anything like that so i haven't
that's still locked so it would oh right
i just got bolt cutters i'm an idiot
[Music]
that's what you get
right of course bolt cutters
only marginally important to pay
attention to the things i actually get
yeah
thank you
i can't close that behind me of course i
can
a cheat unlocked what do you mean a
cheat unlocked
what do you mean
[Music]
okay
you're gonna think those rats aren't
exactly good
elevator runs nine to five why
why would an elevator be timed
where am i going
hey there john here thanks for oh
oh
well i guess that's the end of that i
did enjoy that i did i did wishlisted i
did thank you very much for making this
i've got a different project you can
check out too it's very different from
this one but may strike your fancy oh
one other thing it might be worth taking
a second look around the basement see
you soon
what do you mean basement
what that's a lot of cheats
unlocks modes camera mode what does that
mean speed run mode sure long arms
unlimited roller decks what
what
well no getting back up oh i'm fat
[Laughter]
i see
well this is fascinating uh that's it's
another thing of uh that was in resident
evil too just like the ability to play
it again because you unlock cheats
i just think it's fun that cheats are
built into games
wow i wonder how deep this goes well i'm
finding out also i don't know what else
it meant by have another look around the
basement
it's not like there could be anything
new right
whoa inspect whoa whoa wait a minute
whoa what was that what do you mean huh
[Music]
oh it just means that i can touch things
from a ah
i see
i wonder if i can just go to the
elevator and beat it right away
i wonder if you even have to do any of
this because if you could if you could
skip up here
and press this button then you're
basically done right
and then i win
i did it
i'm the best well there you go
i am pretty incredible
unfriendly difficulty there's still one
more cheat that i haven't done
oh right because i turned on camera mode
that's what it was i was just a camera
oh for getting screenshots and stuff
now i get it well time to go get some
cool screenshots
unfriendly 50 20 mode this may be truly
impossible
well about that i'm not 100 sure
[Music]
[Music]
okay thank you i got the screenshots
let's go grab the thumbnails and run we
gotta get out of here
[Music]
well another job well done everybody
hey
pretty good stuff
i am alarmingly good at this game nah oh
i don't know i don't like the last one
but anyway whatever thank you everybody
so much for watching uh i look forward
to seeing this game fully released i
think that it's going to be fantastic
and i can't wait to see it thank you
everybody so much for watching actually
uh before i go i wanted to give a shout
out to
uh jack's films if you don't know jack's
films i've worked with them in the past
and they're an all-around good dude but
they just released a new game called the
be funny now a kind of um probably the
thing that you would know it closelessly
related to
would be like jack box party pack uh
some of the minigames so it's about
being funny in front of other people if
you guys are interested i can play this
game at some point in the future with
you guys uh and i would love to just
throw some support because i know that
jax films or jack douglas or jack was
kind enough to play in space with
markiplier when it came out and i really
do appreciate that so i wanted to throw
some love their way so give it a try
it's completely free if you want to play
with some friends uh go try it out and
also if you want to see me played
probably over on twitch let me know and
we'll do that in the future and you'll
see just how funny i really am or maybe
how much funnier you are than i am so
thank you and as always i'll see you in
the next video
bye-bye oh god link is in the
description if you want to check this
out be funny now that's
b-e-f-u-n-n-y-n-o-w
exclamation on steam ios and android i
believe so check it out
bye
[Music]